[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: And I'm really
excited for the conversation
that we're going to have today
with a good friend of mine,
Chris Butsch.
Chris and I actually attended
Vanderbilt University together.
And after graduation,
Chris went on
to get a high paying job with
a reputable tech company.
Some of you may have
something similar,
have a similar
experience with that.
And Chris did really
well at this job.
He got promoted, and
he got paid more,
and he got more
responsibilities,
and he got fancier titles.
And then one day he woke up
and he just wasn't happy.
He had become what he calls
a depressed workaholic.
And so that led Chris to leave
that cushy tech company job
and go explore happiness
around the world.
He went on a year
long world tour
to understand and speak with
happiness experts, understand
what makes people happy,
is it possible to be
happy and successful
at the same time.
And he's here to share some
of those tips with us today.
He is an award-winning speaker
and best-selling author,
and a good friend of mine.
And please help me welcome
to the stage, Chris Butsch.
[APPLAUSE]
So Chris, let's start with
just a bit of your background.
And tell us about
yourself and how
you became a globetrotting
happiness expert.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Sure.
Well, first of all,
so thrilled to be here
in the room with some of the
smartest people in the world.
I also know that you're
also from the busiest
people in the world.
So thank you for taking
time off to chat with me.
So my background-- so
when I was 16 years old,
I already knew exactly
what happiness was.
And that was my crush,
Page Whitehouse.
[LAUGHTER] Yeah.
Getting ready for prom--
if you're wondering, I
did take the Duke hat off
before I went to prom.
And that was happiness for me.
If Page will go out with
me, I'll be happy forever.
Well, she did.
And shockingly, I
wasn't happy forever.
I was happy for about a month.
Because that's about
when we broke up.
That wasn't quite happiness.
I'll be happy when
I get straight A's.
So I got straight
A's, and guess what?
It didn't really
make me that happy.
So I thought, all right.
I know.
I know know.
I'll be happy when I
get into Vanderbilt.
So I got into Vanderbilt.
Freshman year came,
and the happiness
highs subsided.
I thought, OK, getting
ready for adult world.
I'll be happy when I
get a high-paying job.
So I got the high paying IT job.
And a year into my work,
I was sitting at my desk
still not feeling very
happy or fulfilled.
And I was running out of ideas.
I started brainstorming.
What's at the end
of the sentence.
I'll be happy when--
I'll be happy when.
I finally figured it out.
I thought I'll be happy
when I have a fast car,
make six figures, and have
a girlfriend who plays
Super Smash Bros. with me--
and a six pack.
I got most of those, and
I still wasn't happy.
And then I started to
feel a little desperate.
I was running out of ideas.
So I settled on the
idea that I'll be happy
when I make enough money.
Well, I made enough money.
It still didn't work.
And one day, I was sitting
at my desk at work,
and I got the email from
my mom that was addressed
to me, Chris, and Greg.
Well, Chris and Greg are
also my uncles' names.
And the email said, let's
not tell the grandkids yet,
but dad's dying.
And in response to the news that
my grandfather, my childhood
hero, was dying when I thought
he was in perfect health,
I felt absolutely nothing.
And that's when I knew
something was seriously wrong.
So I went to check in to talk
to a therapist, my mental health
squad, as I called him.
And eventually, I was
prescribed some antidepressants
shortly after being
told I was depressed.
And these pills helped me
go from negative 5 to 0.
And I thought, that's
not good enough.
That's not good
enough for me, that's
not good enough for
every young person who's
been in this situation--
wondering what
happiness is, wondering
how to treat stress,
anxiety, and depression,
going from negative 5
to 0 isn't good enough.
How do we go from 0 to 10?
And that question has been
driving me ever since.
That was about four years ago.
So at that point, I had
a crossroads in my life.
I had a promotion
offer on my desk.
But I thought I can
help the world more if I
tried to answer this question.
Now, I'm not saying you
should quit your job,
even though that's what I did.
I don't want to [INAUDIBLE]
to come here in a helicopter.
I'm not saying quit your job.
I'm saying I did because I
wanted to find out this answer
and tell everyone else so
you guys didn't have to.
That's what brings me here.
I then went on a
globe trotting tour.
I went to about 31
and change countries,
just asking people on the
street, anyone I could
who'd have a conversation
with me in English,
what does it mean to be happy?
And that's what brings me here.
SPEAKER 1: So I want
to get into your method
and what you prescribe in this
book, and your thoughts on how
we can all achieve
our own happiness.
Because we've hosted
other happiness experts,
we've had Shawn Achor,
and [INAUDIBLE],,
and of course,
Chade-Meng Tan, who
created the Search
Inside Yourself
program that many of our
own Googlers have attended.
So talk to us
about your approach
and what makes it unique.
CHRIS BUTSCH: So my approach
to happiness completely changed
by the time I reached
the Taj Mahal.
I remember that day I
was in a terrible mood.
And I couldn't figure out why.
I was just crabby.
And I was trying to
ruin everyone else's
mood in my friend group.
[LAUGHTER]
So right, happiness
expert, right?
So I go up to my
Australian friend, Helen.
She sees the Taj.
And she just lights up.
She looks like a
little kid who's just
discovered what Halloween is.
She's, oh my God.
Is that real?
[LAUGHTER]
Look at that accent.
It is so special.
I've never seen anything
like it in my life.
And I go over to
her, and I'm, like,
you know, he built
that for his dead wife?
You know that, right?
While he had other wives, and
they had to had to watch him
build that.
How do you think they felt?
[LAUGHTER]
And she turns-- yeah,
I'm speaking short.
So she turns to me, and she's,
like, completely unfazed.
She's, like, oh, come on, mate.
I bet you 1,000 rupee
you're just in a bad mood
because you're dehydrated.
[LAUGHTER]
What?
So sure enough, I take
a huge swig of water,
like I need to right now.
And I feel instantly better.
It just kills my bad mood.
And she's like, eh,
isn't that better?
And I keep getting
this feeling when
I travel, it's, like,
Australians already know
everything about happiness.
They look at America and
they think we're, like,
the muggles of happiness.
It's a secret they
don't know yet.
Give them some time.
So after that moment,
when I realized
that happiness can
be within our grasp
if we just do a
few things right--
up until that point
in my journey,
I had let my inner hippie
make all the decisions.
Yeah, man, you should,
like, go to a drum circle
and it's really happiness.
Yeah.
But I fired that guy, and I
let my inner German take over.
So that' my background.
I'm German.
It seems, like, place!
[GERMAN ACCENT] We shall now
study this most efficient way
to be happy.
[LAUGHTER]
Look at that.
That's a Porsche.
Porsche 911, it's a perfect car.
This makes it perfect.
Happiness formula.
[INAUDIBLE]
So that was when my whole
philosophy on happiness
shifted.
Instead of these ethereal
10,000 foot ideas,
I wanted to find the short
term, instant happiness
fixes, happiness hacks,
as I like to call it.
SPEAKER 1: Let's go into
those happiness hacks.
What are some of the ways that
we can increase our long term
happiness?
Will you call in
just a few minutes?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Yeah.
So there are two types of
happiness in the world.
There's what I call
true happiness, which
is the lasting,
nourishing happiness.
And then there is pleasure,
which is the short term fix.
Right?
So my favorite form
of pleasure is a soda.
And a soda will make you feel
good for about five minutes,
followed by a pinch of regret.
And it's not really-- you
can't build a lifetime
with just drinking a
happy life drink, soda.
Whereas true happiness is
a different form entirely.
So true happiness is something
that you can do in the instant,
but it will last and
have a slow burning
effect on your happiness.
So a challenge I had with
these instant happiness fixes,
or the happiness
hacks, as I like
to call them is that sometimes
I would prescribe one,
and someone would
say, well, I don't
feel like doing that
right now at all.
Like, somebody had
a really bad day.
Let's say here they do.
You're exhausted.
You're getting
home at 9 o'clock.
Oh, my God.
I'm just exhausted.
I can't deal with
this right now.
And your roommate
goes, just be grateful.
You work at Google.
Just be grateful.
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
That doesn't make
you instantly happy.
So I divided happiness
into two different levels.
And these are all forms
of true happiness,
as I like to call them.
So level one is an
acronym I call MESH.
MESH is the baseline
of things you
need to do on a daily,
or every few days, basis
to maintain kind of a
baseline concrete foundation
of happiness.
So MESH stands for meditation,
exercise, sleep, and hydration.
So any time in my
journeys, or if I'm
getting ready for
a speaking gig,
and I just don't feel very
happy, and I can't pin
point why that is,
I go and do my MESH.
And I say, OK, I
meditated this morning.
I exercised.
I got five hours of
sleep last night--
that's where I goofed up.
And I found if I can
consistently do MESH
throughout my life, I'll have
this higher level of baseline
happiness, what positive
psychologists would
call your hedonic setpoint.
So just by doing MESH, you can
keep your hedonic set point
a little higher than
it might be right now.
So that's what I call the
level one of true happiness.
Level two are the
more advanced stuff
you can do once you have
your baseline taken care of.
My acronym for
level two is GRIP.
It's gratitude, relationships,
intellect, and passion.
So once you have your
base needs taken care of,
it's easier to be a
bit more grateful.
So for me, for
gratitude, for example,
when I was growing
up, as I mentioned,
I kept saying things
like I'll be happy when.
I'll be happy when I get
into Vanderbilt. When
I work at Google I'll be happy.
When I'm traveling
the world, I'm
asking these people who
have staggering amounts
of happiness--
rickshaw drivers, janitors,
it's unbelievable.
They started sentences
in different ways.
Instead of I'll be happy
when, they started sentences
with I'm happy because.
I can never forget a rickshaw
driver I was riding with--
actually, this is
a longer story,
because he had a lot of--
this guy had a lot of wisdom.
So I've got a picture of him.
That's me in Bhutan.
Here, we'll just go through
my travel slide show.
[LAUGHTER]
That's me in Bhutan.
That's India.
That's off the side of
Buddha's first [INAUDIBLE]..
I was meditating until
these Indian eighth graders
came and surrounded me.
[LAUGHTER]
That's Sweden.
So I was asked by the
Swedish to come to Sweden
and teach them about happiness.
For those of you who
don't know, Sweden's
one of the happiest
countries in the world.
So that's, like, Michael Phelps
asking for swimming lessons.
I should go to Sweden, and
you all should teach me.
Do a little bit of happiness
in both directions.
Oh, yeah.
So I visited a
Buddhist monastery.
Just to learn mindfulness
meditation, I check into one.
Turns out they run some Buddhist
monasteries just like Airbnbs.
You just hit them up by email.
And say, I'd like
to stay for 12 days.
They might charge you
$40 a day, but that'll
cover your meals and expenses.
So I scheduled some time to
visit this Buddhist monastery
in Mississippi.
[LAUGHTER]
Because when you
think the epicenter
of Vietnamese Buddhist
thought, you go to Mississippi.
So [INAUDIBLE]
and imagine you're
about to walk into a
Buddhist monastery.
What kind of things
would you see?
would you smell?
What would you expect
the monks to be doing?
Maybe meditating, cleaning,
like dragging that rake
through the sand or
whatever they do?
None of that-- so I walk in, and
this monk hands me a margarita.
I said, is this a margarita?
He said, no.
It's-- does anyone
have any guesses?
It sounds like margarita,
but starts with a "B."
If you can guess it, I'll
give you a free book.
AUDIENCE: Beerita.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Beerita,
no, not quite, we're
at a Buddhist monastery--
AUDIENCE: Buddharita?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Buddharita!
Yeah.
So they hand me a Buddharita.
So I walk in.
It's a Buddharita.
They're watching
a Bollywood movie,
and they're doing
karaoke in there.
[LAUGHTER]
Turns out, even Vietnamese
devout Buddhist monks
will take what they call a
lazy week, where they just
have a staycation and hang out.
So I showed up in the
middle of lazy week.
And I'm doing--
within 20 minutes,
I'm doing karaoke in a
language I don't speak.
But later that week, I actually
learned mindfulness meditation
and got back into
the rhythm of things.
So after that long
diversion-- here we are.
So that's Sati.
Sati was the most
memorable person
I spoke to in my entire
journey in 31 countries.
I get in Sati's rickshaw, a
little outside the Taj Mahal.
And I say, Sati, I'm a
student of happiness.
I'm traveling the world to ask
people what happiness means.
So what does
happiness mean to you?
And he lights up.
And he's instantly
got the answer.
He goes, ah,
happiness, my friend.
Happiness-- there are
two secrets to happiness.
First, is that
happiness is love.
Too many people in this world
wait around to receive love.
What we forget as a species
is that we can give love.
Sometimes in the middle of the
day, I still feel depressed.
So what I'll do is I'll drive
down to the Mother Teresa
house on the Ganges River.
And I'll pour soup into the
mouths of those less fortunate
than me.
And I'll create love.
And as long as I
can create love,
I'll be the happiest
man in the world.
I said, Sati, that's beautiful.
But you said there are
two secrets to happiness.
What's the other one?
He said, ah, you need
to find a hot wife.
[LAUGHTER]
Sati, we were doing so well.
So what else is there?
So gratitude is also important.
He said I'm happy because I
can feed my family tonight.
I'm happy because I have a job.
I'm happy because I have
unlimited love in my life.
So very easy gratitude
hack is rather than
start a sentence with
I'm grateful for, which
for me personally doesn't really
work that well, I ask myself
I'm happy because.
And I'll answer that every day.
It's OK if the answers
are the same every day.
You've just got
to remind yourself
why you're already happy.
So instead of I'll
be happy when,
and setting a goal for this
state you'll never reach--
I'll be happy when,
I'll be happy when--
remind yourself why
you're already happy.
I'm happy because.
SPEAKER 1: Let's talk about
the other part of that acronym.
You mentioned relationships.
Talk to us about how you
maintain relationships.
I think a lot of folks,
you know, especially
in the millennial crowd,
they've graduated from college
in the last four or five years.
They're now in their first
job, maybe mid to late 20s.
And I think a lot of folks
find a sense of sadness,
because a lot of the
relationships that they
had when they were younger
start to fade away.
People grow apart.
Talk to me.
Talk to us about
your relationships
and how you maintain those.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Yeah, absolutely.
So this was definitely a day
when I was not traveling now.
I was back home in Atlanta,
just me in front of a laptop
doing happiness research,
like, full German.
[GERMAN] find most efficient
way to be happy today.
That was on my to do list,
find efficient happiness.
So there was a
Ted talk about it.
There was a study called
a Harvard Grant study.
Has anyone heard of this before?
Yeah, a couple of hands.
The Harvard Grant study is--
in the 1930s,
Harvard researchers
decided to start collecting
millions of data points
from hundreds of Bostonian
men, Harvard grads, or Harvard
undergrads, but also men from
underprivileged neighborhoods.
They didn't really have a
strong objective back then.
They just wanted to
collect a ton of data
that they could then
extrapolate ideas
from later in the century.
So in 2013, 75 years after
the inception of the study,
a guy named Robert
Waldinger did a Ted talk
revealing what they found
after 75 years, the number one
indicator of a
happy, healthy life.
Like, the one thing that kept
these guys happier and living
longer and more successful
throughout their entire lives.
And that one thing was
their relationships.
And not the quantity of their
relationships, but the quality.
So these guys-- one thing that
the happiest guys in the Grant
study all had in common was
they had five close friends.
And I took that idea
and I ran with it.
And it turns out the
happiest societies
in the world generally all
have some format of that five
good friend rule.
So Okinawa, for example--
Okinawa is what they call a
blue zone, a UN designated
area where they have a unique
amount of centenarians,
people who live past 100.
So sociologists around the
world love to study blue zones,
because they can extrapolate
the secrets of long life
and happiness.
And one of the secrets of the
Okinawan society is that they
what they call a moai, M-O-A-I.
I think that's right, M-O-A-I.
So the moai is when
Okinawans are born,
their families find them five
close friends that they'll have
throughout their entire life.
And you'll see
pictures of Okinawans
with their moais over 100
years after they were created.
I think, as a society,
we've lost touch
of the quality of relationship.
Because there are websites
that I will not name that
tend to value
quantity over quality.
When I hold back my
networking and trying
to meet a million
people in the world,
and instead pour my
resources into growing
five chosen relationships,
my happiness skyrocketed.
So that all being said, here
is a very simple tool for,
as David said,
reconnecting with somebody.
Maybe your best
friend in college
who you haven't
spoken to in years.
Facebook-- one thing
I love about Facebook
is that it tells you when
your friends' birthdays are.
The one thing I love to do
every day is call that person.
I pick up the phone,
and I call them and just
have a quick conversation.
Sometimes I'll leave a voicemail
and I sing them happy birthday.
But think about-- imagine
it's your birthday today.
And 100 people write on your
Facebook wall, happy birthday.
But one guy even
wrote HB on my wall.
Wow, thanks.
HB?
I can tell you really put
a lot of thought into that.
So on to HB, imagine
100 people wrote
HB on your wall and one person
called you and wished you
happy birthday and catch up.
It makes so much difference.
And what did that cost
you to pick up the phone?
What did that cost to
them to make the call?
Five minutes-- five minutes
to reignite a relationship.
That's how I
reconnected with David.
Probably I called you on your
birthday, or I just called you.
And around that
time, and because I
reignited a relationship that
I cared about, here I am.
SPEAKER 1: Here we are.
I think Myspace was
closed at the top eight.
But I guess we're talking
the top five friends which
we should consider.
We're going to go to audience
questions here in a little bit.
So consider those, and
we'll get the mic set up.
I'm sure you have
some more crazy travel
stories from your time abroad.
You have any you want to share?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Let's see.
Oh, there was this
time in Cozumel.
I love talking to cabbies.
Cabbies, rickshaw
drivers generally--
they're sort of undercover
sociologists and psychologists,
because who else listens to
somebody else's life story
every single day.
These people have so
many conversations.
They're generally
buckets of wisdom.
And I love talking
to these guys.
So we got in the cab in
Cozumel, and I said the usual.
Hey, Miguel, I'm
studying happiness.
I love asking people
what makes them happy.
And he cuts me
off, and he goes, I
will take you to where
they make happiness.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, what does that mean?
And he doesn't ask
me where I'm going,
or where I want to go, you
know, his job as a cab driver.
Instead, he just drives me
to where they make happiness.
So I'm in Cozumel.
Does anyone have a guess where
they would make happiness?
It begins with a "T."
AUDIENCE: Tequila?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Yes!
It's a tequila farm.
He drove me to his
cousin's tequila farm.
[LAUGHTER]
He pulls out this little--
I watched the whole process.
It's actually
pretty fascinating.
And at the very
end of the process,
tequila is dribbling down
the sugar chute that's
capturing the perfect
amount of sugar,
and it just drips into
this little Dixie cup.
And he hands me the
Dixie cup, and he goes,
my friend, your journey is over.
[LAUGHTER]
That's a wrap.
All right.
Right.
I get home.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
We're going to go to
audience questions here.
Just start lining up at the mic.
And in the meantime, I
want to go back to GRIP.
So we talked about gratitude.
We talked about relationships.
Talk to us about the
last two in the acronym.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Yeah, intellect
and passions-- those
are challenging ones.
So for intellect,
what I like to do
is set a Google alert
on my favorite topics.
That might be happiness,
positive psychology.
I also love cars, so Porsche.
And I'll just, like, will you
email me the latest articles
on those topics.
And then all of a sudden, I've
got a pile of reading material
for if I'm on the subway or
if I'm in an Uber or whatever.
So I'm constantly
sharpening my intellect.
Personally, I'm also
a big fan of the--
I know they're a bit
controversial-- but the apps
that you can play brain
training games on.
They've been in
and out of the news
because they've made some
marketing claims that
may or may not have backing.
But personally, I've
felt that they actually
work and keep my brain sharp.
And here's really
kind of a quirky one
I've been doing lately.
And I welcome your
judgmental stares.
I was tutoring my neighbor's son
and getting him ready for SSAT.
And he didn't have
the answer key around.
So as an adult, I just had to
go through the SSAT practice
questions and just
answer them myself.
And I realized that
the questions designed
to challenge elementary
and middle schoolers
are actually pretty
good for jostling
the parts of the brain, like
the prefrontal cortex, insular
cortex, et cetera, for an
adult. So sometimes before a gig
or if I'm just trying
to jog my creativity,
I will download an SSAT
practice test off the internet
and just take it.
So that's intellect.
Do three of those, and
you'll be the smartest
person in the world.
SPEAKER 1: Chris, you brought
your book with us today.
Talk to us about the experience
of publishing your own book.
And what folks who
read it can expect
to get out from reading that.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Sure.
So I drafted the book
in Microsoft Word.
And I just had it
sitting in this document
and wondered what are
my next options, right?
Traditionally, you
can self publish.
It means you send it
to Amazon or whoever.
And they'll send you back
your book and books in a box.
You can go for traditional
publishing, where you get
an agent, then pitch it around.
And you might get a bite at
a major or a small publishing
house.
And they may or may not
take some creative control.
That might be three
months, or three years.
And I thought, I don't like
the idea of self-publishing.
That doesn't feel
really like I'd
be joining the industry
if I just self-published.
I also don't feel like I want
to lose any creative control.
So there is a third
option now called
hybrid publishing, where you
work with a boutique publisher.
But if you pay some
of the costs up front,
they'll let you retain higher
royalties and creative control.
That's exactly what I did with
a small company called BookLogix
in Alpharetta, Georgia.
So they are my formal publisher.
That's my publisher, the
little B on the book.
What that let me do is
retain creative control.
And we went from books
sitting in a Word document
to edited critiques and
books in hand, in about four,
five months.
And that can be
pretty intensive.
I don't know if
you work full-time
at Google, if you'll have time
to do that in four months.
But know that it's possible.
If you have a book hanging
around in your head,
know that it's never
been easier to publish
your own work, your own book.
So, after that, I
wanted to galvanize
all my friends and family
into supporting the book.
The traditional school of
thought is to launch on Amazon.
But I wanted to do something
a bit more fun and gamified.
So I ran a Kickstarter
campaign to fund
the book, and all of my
upfront self-publishing costs.
So the thing I love
about Kickstarter
is you get a ping on your phone
every time somebody donates.
So I was connecting with some of
my old teachers, my old English
High School teacher.
Yeah, I'm running
this online fundraiser
to publish my first book.
Oh, that sounds pretty cool.
I get back to my car and
I get a ping on my phone.
Mrs. Finch donated $120
to your Kickstarter.
And that's an isolated case.
But if you run your own
Kickstarter campaign,
or whichever
fundraising platform
you choose, and you put your own
creative creation on the line,
and you see people
from your past life,
and your current boss, your
best friend, his best friend,
pouring money to help you give
birth to something that you
care about,
something that you've
put your heart and soul into--
it was the most amazing,
humbling experience
of my entire life.
And from a German
perspective, it
helped me pre-sell
my first 500 copies.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: We're headed to
what's in the book in a second,
but we've got a live
question right here.
Go to that.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, man.
Thanks for coming.
So I've seen some
research that suggests
that most of each
person's happiness level
is predetermined
by their genetics
and there's only a little
bit that we can affect.
Do you think that's true?
Like, what do you
think about that?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Yeah.
If I can remember the numbers
off the top of my head,
I wonder if it was
[INAUDIBLE] work.
I think it was 50% is genetic.
10% is controlled by factors
outside of your control--
the weather, the
stocks, et cetera.
And they say 40% is completely
within your control.
So 40% is a lot.
That's the difference
between a D minus and an A
plus in happiness.
So the challenge is, as it
goes with a lot of happiness
research, happiness
is very subjective.
It's difficult to measure
happiness in objective terms.
You can't really
quantify exactly
how happy glad people make
you, because you can't just
show up in a [INAUDIBLE]
with an MRI machine.
You just throw people in it,
and measure the difference.
That being said,
they have measured
our longitudinal
effects of meditation.
And I think, more subjectively,
the self-reported effects
of [INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
So to expand on your question.
Do I believe in
the 50-40-10 rule,
or do I believe in some of this
more subjective or open-ended
happiness research?
I can't find any
counter evidence to it.
I haven't really found work by
Chade-Meng Tan, or Shawn Achor,
or Sonya Lyubomirsky
that I disagree with.
I've found subjective
evidence in my own life.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: We've got
another live question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is taller than me.
Thanks for being here.
I think this topic is
definitely [INAUDIBLE]..
We've all seen at
least the headline
of the [INAUDIBLE] millennial
burnout article and things
like that.
So I was wondering,
from your perspective,
why did you need
to be number one?
I know that makes this
question, like, hard to answer.
And what about being millennial,
[INAUDIBLE] question,
and, on the flip side, like, how
does being a millennial informs
the solution [INAUDIBLE]?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Thank
you for asking that.
It's funny.
The number one feedback I get
on the book is, it's great.
Why is millennial the title?
One of my family friends,
their daughter read the book.
And then, when she
went off to college,
she couldn't find
her copy of the book.
That was because her mother
had stolen it and hidden it
in her room because
she wanted to read it.
And anyone over 35
will read the book
and ask me the same question.
Why are you orienting
this just to millennials?
And to be honest, I don't
really have a good answer.
I've actually been thinking
about retitling the book
to just making happiness.
Because I do want to appeal
to a broader audience.
I think this positive
psychology, these happiness
hacks, this knowledge
of how our brain works
and how to improve
our lifestyles
applies to every generation.
I just wanted to
galvanize millennials
into taking advantage
of it because I
feel that we're poised to make
the most change in the world
right now that we
desperately need.
I think the challenges specific
to the millennial audience
that we grew up with--
I'm 28-- is social
media, I think,
has made the most impact.
I think social
media was originally
conceived, business objectives
aside, to bring us together
as a society.
So if you can catalyze the
way that people communicate
and make a fence, that should
be great for humankind, right?
But I think what we've done is
use that not as a supplement
or a catalyst in
social behavior,
but as a replacement, right?
So why would I call
up a friend if I
can just Facebook chat him?
Why would I try to
connect with this person
again over coffee, if I can just
connect with them on Facebook
at friend whatever.
So I think what
also goes with that
is a phenomenon they call
impressions management.
So as a species, we've evolved.
We are the offspring of
the smartest, most powerful
among our species.
And the way that we've
shown that off in the past
is by what they
called peacocking.
Right?
So making ourselves look smart,
intelligent, and impressive
to the small audience
that's around us.
What Facebook, Instagram, and
social media sites have given
us is a microzone.
So instead of peacocking
to just five people
that we might care
about, we're now
trying to peacock to 1,500
people on a daily basis.
That's a staggering amount of
pressure to put on ourselves.
I remember back in college, I
had two friends, Ann and Dave.
They were that couple that
dated throughout college.
Everyone thought, oh,
they're that perfect couple.
We need to be like Ann and Dave.
Well, I knew Ann
and Dave better.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
I knew-- and these are
not their real names,
but they know who they are.
So one night, I was talking
to Ann, and Dave came in.
And he demanded to know
who she was on the phone
with earlier that day.
Who does that?
Who were you on the phone
call with earlier today?
She's like, none
of your business.
She's the jealous type.
He's holding a pizza.
And he takes the pizza out and
throws it against the wall.
I'm, like, this is
not a perfect couple.
And yet everyone
thinks they are,
because they post beautiful
pictures on Facebook
all the time.
How many couples are out
there judging themselves
against the couples that are
on Facebook that look perfect.
And everyone looks
perfect, because you're all
taking beautiful pictures in
front of the Eiffel Tower,
her legs popping.
But that's just not real life.
So I think because
we all spend so much
time in this arena that's not
reflective of the humdrumness
and the challenges of real life,
we have higher expectations
for each of ourselves.
And it's OK to remind ourselves
that we're all just human.
And the best reminder
that we're all human
is to spend time
with other humans.
SPEAKER 1: We've
got a live question.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thanks so much for coming today.
One question I just
had was how do you
balance gratitude and ambition?
So kind of the idea of being
grateful for what you have,
and, also, at the
same time, from
a young millennial perspective,
the desire to want more?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Sure.
Yeah.
So how do you balance
gratitude and ambition?
How are you grateful
for what you have
without stifling your ambition?
Everyone in this room
is incredibly ambitious.
I think-- I wouldn't
see them as dichotomous.
I would see them as
supplementary to each other.
So the really important
thing to remind ourselves
about happiness is that it's
a high performance fuel.
So a grand fallacy
of the idea I'll
be happy when is, if we
wait for all that happiness
to come at the end of
this goalpost, that's
a lot of high performance fuel
that we're not getting that we
need to reach that goal.
So if you spend your night
journaling and reminding
yourself what you're
already happy for,
I can't imagine a scenario
where that could possibly
stifle innovation or ambition,
at least in my own life.
It reminds you how far
you've come and reminds you
how far you have yet to go.
So I'm grateful for
what I already have.
And that gratitude is motivating
me to continue to get more.
And maybe I can
make a difference
in other people's lives to
make them grateful as well.
SPEAKER 1: Chris, anything
else that you want
to add before we wrap up here?
Any other happiness tips for
the Googlers watching here now.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Yeah, absolutely.
So I'm probably the
least intelligent person
in this room.
So I would love to
know, because Google
is known as one of the
happiest campuses in the world.
I'm curious to know
what do you find either
makes you happy at
work, or what are
your personal secrets
for happiness,
or what does Google do
to make you guys happy?
I'm just curious
about it, myself.
SPEAKER 1: Anyone in the
audience want to jump in?
CHRIS BUTSCH: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: In my personal
opinion, working hour
flexibility.
Like, it takes off a lot of the
pressure if you have something
that comes [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So I used to
work for IBM for 15 years
before joining Google.
And one of the striking
differences that personally
made the biggest
impression on me
and probably influences
my happiness here more
than anything is the feeling
of empowerment to change.
And I think that actually
drives a lot of the, ultimately,
down the line, a lot of
the perks that people talk
about when they mention Google.
But all of that, I feel,
comes from being a part
to change the group.
AUDIENCE: One thing that
makes a big difference
for me is this concept
of psychological safety
that we have.
Are you familiar with that?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Now
tell me about it.
AUDIENCE: I'm not probably
the best person to explain it.
But Google did a study
before I started, years ago,
about what makes effective
teams at Google, what
makes them the most effective.
And the big thing they
found was that the teams had
a culture of
psychological safety,
meaning that people feel
comfortable giving suggestions
without feeling someone was
going to make fun of them,
or, like, everyone is just
comfortable being open
and being themselves.
And that makes a big
difference for me.
Off topic, but you forgot to
talk about the "P" in GRIP.
And I was curious about that.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Yeah,
passions, sure.
So very-- thank you
for calling me out.
For some lifelong
challenges, how
do you answer the question,
what are my passions?
And what I've found works is
simply a brute force approach.
Try everything.
Sample everything.
I think finding your passions
is like finding metal
on the beach.
You just have to wave around
until you hear a beep.
My friend Mark,
for example, Mark
thought he wanted
to teach English.
He thought that he'd be
passionate about that.
So he went to go teach English.
And he realized-- I
think he was teaching
to freshman in high school.
And he didn't like it.
He liked some things about
it, but not [INAUDIBLE]..
So what he did is he sat down
and he wrote out what he likes
and what he didn't like.
I like teaching.
I don't like ninth graders.
[LAUGHTER]
And I don't like English.
But he heard a beep in
his metal detector, right?
So he thought, OK.
I'm going to try teaching
math to ninth graders.
And the school
allowed that change.
He's, like, oh, I love
teaching and math.
I still don't like
ninth graders.
So now he teaches
math to fifth graders.
So I think to go out on a
limb and just try and sample
as many things here
and around the world
as you can, whether it's belly
dancing, or hula hooping,
or coding, whatever
it is, trying it.
And then being
mindful of that beep.
I think I kind of like this.
And then tweaking it from there
is how you find your passions.
And passions to me
are things, activities
that we fall in love
with, just like we
fall in love with a spouse
or a member of our family.
So passion is just
another form of love.
And as Sati told us,
that's one of the two
secrets for happiness.
[LAUGHTER]
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: You've got
a live question here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you were talking
about how to be happy.
And actually, one
of the things that
came to mind for me was that I
know when we think about happy,
I think a lot of people are--
their religion makes them happy.
But I also feel like
there's this subset to that,
their religion makes
them very unhappy.
And so just curious
kind of what--
I don't know, just
in your travels,
what you experienced
in terms of religion
and how that relates
to people's happiness.
And secondly, since we're
talking about ambition,
what is your end goal?
What are you looking to do?
What would you love to do next
10, 15 years, or accomplish?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Thank
you for asking.
So the first question--
first question is on--
SPEAKER 1: Religion.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Yes,
religion question--
so when religion
makes you happy--
there is a metric on the
UN World Happiness Report,
which is a report the UN
puts out for free every year,
I think since 2014,
that measures and rates
every country's happiness.
How did they measure that?
They send out surveys
in each country
that had six metrics on them.
And the people respond
and they measure happiness
based on that.
One of the questions
pertains to social belonging.
And it's the simplest
question on the entire survey.
The question is, do you
feel that when times--
when times get tough,
do you have one person
in your life to call?
And it's sad because
a lot of people
answer no to that question.
And I think organized
religion is,
for a lot of people, that
place, a place full of people
that they can count on.
It can also be a place
for meditation and prayer,
a place for introspection,
and for gratitude.
And I think that's when
religion can make you happy.
I think when religion
can make you unhappy
is if it stifles natural
sources of happiness.
If it stifles ambition, and
it says you can't do this,
you can't do that.
If it's a microphone for
oppression or for judgment,
I think that's what religion
can make you unhappy.
That's about as
politically correct
a response I can give
to that question.
I think the second question,
regarding ambition--
my ambition-- my
ambition is to visit
every country in the world and
continue to study happiness.
I want to understand and try
to help in countries where
happiness isn't a priority
or is such a distant thought
that it takes a distant
priority to survival.
So I think even for people
in desperate situations,
there are ways that they can
increase their happiness, which
in turn creates
improved [INAUDIBLE]..
So that's part of my
ambition, travel the world,
continue traveling the world.
Continue writing--
I have a second book
in the works with a new wording
on top of it called MESH.
It's based on my MESH platform--
meditation, exercise, sleep,
and hydration.
And it's going to
be called MESH,
how to take better
care of your brain.
And continue writing and
helping people in any way
that I find I can do that most
efficiently, most efficiently,
over the next as long as I can
speak for the next 50 years,
anyway I can find to help.
SPEAKER 1: Chris, how can
we follow your journey?
CHRIS BUTSCH: Sure.
So I just got an Instagram.
I created it in the
airport on the way here.
I'm not joking.
So if you want to be
my 27th follower--
[LAUGHTER]
--that looks so cool.
That's my Instagram name.
I promise to post on it.
That's my site.
And otherwise, if you'd
like a copy of the book,
we're selling them
in the back corner.
I see Andrew back there.
I'll also be back
there signing books.
And just be grateful.
Just pass along anything that
you've found valuable today,
just pass it along to your
friends, family and people
you find in your life that
[INAUDIBLE] happiness.
Maybe, if we have time
for one more question,
this would help me to help other
people-- what did you guys find
valuable in today's talk?
What's your number one takeaway?
AUDIENCE: I think that
frameworks in particular
are really helpful.
It might just be,
like, the nature
of most Googlers
and our OCDness,
but usually I think those
frameworks are really helpful.
They're easy to follow
and very catchy.
So those were my main takeaways.
CHRIS BUTSCH: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so
much, Chris, for coming.
Let's give a big round
of applause to Chris.
[APPLAUSE]